ننتقل الان الى عمر حلبي الذي ينضم الينا
من ريفي حلب في جندريس واعتقد انه في مكان
يتابع فيه عمليات الانقاذ نحاول ان نقترب
اكثر من المشهد هناك اليك الكلمه عمرو
صحيح عبد السلام انا الان في موقع جديد
هنا في ناحيه جنديرس بريف في حلب الغربي
في حلب الشمالي حيث تتواصل وعلى مدار
الساعه عمليات الانقاذ من اجل البحث عن
المفقودين تحت هذا الركام هذا الموقع الذي
دمرت تماما مجمع سكني تم او دمر بفعل هذا
الزلزال
ومنذ ان ندمر وفرق الدفاع المدني وكما
ترون يواصلون اعمالهم من اجل البحث عن
المفقودين تم انتشال العديد من الضحايا
والعالقين تحت الانقاض كان هناك بعضهم على
قيد الحياه لكن العدد الاكبر الذين تم
انتشالهم من هذا الموقع كانوا قد فقدوا
حياتهم
الان فرق الدفاع المدني تقول انه هنالك
عددا من الاشخاص ما يزالون موجودين تحت
الركام ويحاولون الان ان يقوموا
باستخراجهم ويحاولون عن طريق اقاربهم ان
يحددوا مكانهم لكنه حتى الان لم ينجحوا
التعرف على اماكنهم لذلك نرى هذه الاليات
الثقيله تقوم بجرف
وازاله دفعه دفعه من الركام حتى يتم
التوصل الى اماكن هذه الجثث تحت الركام
عبد السلام الحقيقه في اكثر الموقع ايضا
في ناحيه جنديرس هنالك دمار كبير وتتواصل
كذلك عمليات
الانقاذ وعمليات البحث على المفقودين تحت
الانقاض مجلس المحلي هنا في جنديره قال
بان اعداد الضحايا ارتفعت الى 5
[موسيقى]